whose land is this
my land
well well well our war hero has arrived
you've been a good choice going back
here this is our the finest wealthiest
and most beautiful people on God's Earth
maybe outsmarted everybody
they have the same
who gets the oil
Sean I got a question you like women
that's my weakness
well we mix these families together and
that state money flows the right
direction it'll come to us
that's how you are I don't know what you
said but it must have been Indian for
handsome devil fish
[Music]
why did you come here
you're scared of him
oh easy
he's the nicest man in the world
yo Sage their time is over
we got to take back control of our home
I was sent down from Washington DC to
see about these murders
we have so many deaths we've lost count
it's just
man look seems more like an epidemic
than bad luck to me
[Music]
no say just die by the enemy
do not let them die alone
evil surrounds my heart
pick a side
I don't even know if you love me anymore
kill these men who killed my family
did your wife say who she was most
afraid of
[Applause]
to go through something you're going to
regret for the rest of your life
[Music]
I ain't got nothing but regret